really interesting update from Germany's
new defense minister he's only been
officially in the job for one day and
today he was defending his country I'll
just go through some of the points that
he made he has literally just finished
finished speaking in the last minute or
so so he said it was wrong to give the
impression that Germany was standing in
the way but as you said he said that
they were basically weighing up the pros
and cons of sending those tanks and that
they needed to look at things like the
number of stocks and how those tanks
would be sent and time and Logistics and
that while they were doing that he said
they had no problem that Partners did
that as well they said he said that they
also discussed about Partners exporting
their own stocks no decision on that yet
but it he's very keen to make this point
that they aren't standing in the way I
think the other thing that was really
important was that he started his whole
conference to the Press by listing some
of the things that Germany has done so
he underlined the fact that they're
going to send and these murder fighting
Vehicles 40 of those due to be delivered
by March also underlining that they're
sending other support really trying to
make the point clear that Germany is by
no means letting the side down when it
comes to supporting Ukraine but also
underlining that point that many
analysts have said to me over the last
few days that feeling that they really
need to be cautious when they take this
next step of sending in these battle
tanks and he said that um when they're
looking at the pros and cons they had to
balance the pros and cons in the
interest of Europe and the German
population and I think that's a really
interesting point because as we've been
talking today there has been this idea
that the chancellor for example is very
concerned about making wrong decisions
and making decisions very carefully to
ensure that if they send these tanks for
example that it doesn't lead to an
escalation in the war and that is a
point that seems to be supported by a
majority of the German public who in
recent polls by public TV the majority
of them didn't support sending the
leopard tanks leopard two tanks they
said that they did support Ukraine but
this seems to be for many people a step
too far so caution again on the part of
Germany here people who were hoping for
a big announcement today were sending
the tanks that clearly doesn't sound
like it's going to happen What will be
interesting now is to see whether what's
been discussed behind closed doors is
enough to appease Partners like Poland
who are really getting frustrated and
have already already threatened to send
their stocks of these Leopard 2 tanks
without permission